hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys weltweite
gibt's wieder eine tolle motiv torte und
zwar habe ich eine zum anlass zum
aktuellen anlass gemacht für den ramadan
und zwar aktuell noch der ramadan monats
aber ende des monats wenn dann das
fasten vorbei ist kommen hier drei tage
sozusagen das ramadanfest und da zu
diesem anlass habe ich diese torte
gebacken genau oder trifft man sich mit
der familie haut also bei uns ist es
immer so wir gehen dann meinen eltern
oder wir gehen zu meinen eltern
frühstücken die ganze familie kommt
zusammen oder muss man eigentlich immer
als sieger die eltern so muss man
gefallen geht hat sich international
wieder alle die familie die freunde die
bekannte die nachbarschaft also da
versucht man wirklich jeden und
normalerweise gibt es dann immer so
fackler war und andere süßspeisen
aber viele haben sich eben auch dieses
jahr eine torte gewünscht deswegen habe
ich jetzt eben auch eine torte für sie
da trifft dann dann tut man aus respekt
den älteren die handy küssen und die
kinder die bekommen dann meistens was
süßes oder bisserl taschengeld deswegen
kennt das fiel auch unter dem namen
zucker festival weiter mit aber er hat
mir meine eltern und mein leben die
eltern entweder bonbons oder geld genau
deswegen laufe ich drei tage lang mit
lauter fünf euro schein in meiner
hosentasche um also die polizei wenn ihr
mich auch ein halt also auf halt
irgendwo die fünf euro ich bin kein
drogendealer dessen für die krisen viele
kids bestimmt ja nur sagen zum optischen
retorte in den moscheen ist meist so
dass da so richtig tolle orientalische
fließen sind diesen zu boden sehr
farbenfroh und danken wir ein bisschen
daran orientiert und habe auch ein
muster gestaltet und ja und in der
moschee in barßel übrigens sind zwei
säulen der mitte habe ich gemalt habe
ich hosen hin gemalt in meiner jugend ja
meine jugend halten eine bushaltestelle
die kürzlichen plan zur anzeige gekommen
erzählt mir jetzt machen sie ja und im
innern ist eine dattel torte mit einer
pistazien creme und ich würde sagen
starten einfach mal direkt bevor wir
noch mehr geschichten über moratinos los
geht's mit dem teig für den teig habe
ich mir jetzt
das sind orte ausgesucht und zwar finde
ich dass datteln wirklich sehr
orientalisch sind vor allem zur
jahreszeit passen sie sehr gut mit dazu
denn das fastenbrechen beginnen die
meisten immer mit einer dattel deswegen
ein saftiger basteltag der auch sehr
aromatisch ist mit ein bisschen zimt und
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
teig brauche ich 190 gramm datteln da
zähle ich das in stein der gewicht also
das sind jetzt keine steine mit 300
milliliter milch 100 milliliter wasser
drei eier eine prise salz einer prise
zimt 55 gramm zucker 150 gramm mehl 30
kampfstärke und 15 teelöffel backpulver
100 gramm gemahlene mandeln und 100
gramm gestiftete oder gehackte mandeln
und 100 gramm butter bei den datteln ist
so da habe ich jetzt einen teil noch von
meiner tante die aktionäre auch mit
mitgebrachten also aus saudi arabien
da war noch welche mitarbeiter musste
ich auch selber im steinen unternehme
ich auch immer ganz gerne diese bio
datteln die sind auch fair trade und
zwar gibt es die von bp und das finde
ich immer ganz gut um die sind bereit im
stein das spart man sich einfach die
abrechnung jetzt nämlich zuerst einmal
die dattel und jetzt die zwei
flüssigkeiten milch und wasser
die kommen jetzt in einen topf und
werden kurz aufgekocht
sobald die flüssigkeit aufgekocht ist
gebe ich jetzt hier zu den datteln mit
dazu und zwar für die datteln jetzt zwar
weich aber immer noch zu fest und sie zu
mixen und so kann man sich das etwas
einfacher machen hier heiß übergießen
man könnte nämlich ein bisschen
einweichen ich kurz zur seite
und jetzt kann ich bereits in einer
küchenmaschine das geht natürlich auch
ohne küchenmaschine mit einem
handrührgerät die eier gemeinsam mit dem
salz und nimmt sind und dem zucker
richtig cremig verwirrung die eier
zucker maße ist jetzt sehr cremig
gerührt das hat jetzt etwa drei bis fünf
minuten gedauert und in der zeit sind
jetzt auch schon die datteln eingeweiht
und die werde ich jetzt kurz fein
pürieren
die dattel kommen jetzt mit zwei eier
zucker mischung
jetzt braucht ihr auch kein
handrührgerät oder keine küchenmaschine
mails machen was alles mit dem
schneebesen mit dem teig habe jetzt das
ganze mit dem schneebesen ein bisschen
einrühren und mache ich jetzt noch mit
toller tag später schmecken wird also
die datteln sind wirklich sehr
aromatisch sagt es reicht schon
und jetzt kommen noch die trockenen
zutaten mit rein
sie werden auch kurz eingerührt
und die mutter habe ich jetzt bereits
geschmolzen die sitzt auch leicht
abgekühlt jetzt gebe ich einen teil des
teiges hier mit rein dann vermischt sich
nämlich besser und einfacher ist es kurz
verrühren
jetzt einfach nichts mit dem restlichen
teig geben und gut verrühren
den teig für dich jetzt in meine
vorbereitete backform bleibt jetzt in
turin auf 22 cm eingestellt und der teig
wird später so ungefähr 5 cm hoch das
wäre den kuchen etwas höher haben wollt
könnt ihr den teig zum beispiel auch
noch mal packen und dann ist apropos zu
hoch
und so will jetzt einfach heimischen
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für ungefähr 30 bis 35 minuten gebacken
während der teig jetzt noch im ofen ist
werde schon mal die creme zu bereiten
dafür habe ich jetzt bereits eine weiße
schokolade hergestellt also sahne
aufkochen lassen und schokolade mit dazu
gegeben und jetzt hat sich die schön
gelöst und ist schön geschmeidig und
damit jetzt auch eine richtig tolle
orientalische torte wird wird diese
weise schokoladen ganache zu einer
pistazien creme
dafür habe ich jetzt hier 120 gramm
pistazien und werde jetzt erst noch fein
mahlen
und ich habe gleich ein bisschen mehr
kann als er gestellt eben auch später
weil ich ja die torte bestreichen muss
habe jetzt aber hier nur noch 350 gramm
drin also die habe ich vorhin abgemessen
und jetzt früher ich die pistazien in
die 350 gramm weise kanal kurz verrühren
und so hat man da eben nur einmal die
arbeit und hat die füllung und die creme
zum bestreichen in einem fertig und
jetzt habe ich hier schon mal beides
ungefüllt weil es abdecken und dann
einfach bei zimmertemperatur bzw in
einem kühlen raum lagern
falls sie am gleichen tag verwenden
wollte könnte es auch kurz in den
kühlschrank stellen bis dieser
streichfähige konsistenz hat wie zum
beispiel nutella jetzt warte ich einfach
noch auf den teig lasten auch komplett
abkühlen und danach wer die treppe
zusammengesetzt
zweite wurden gebacken sind beide schon
durch gekühlt und ich hatte sie auch für
eine halbe stunde im kühlschrank und die
creme ist mittlerweile auch abgekühlt
und ich werde ich die tortenböden einmal
waagerechte teilen geht am besten mit
einer torten säge
nämlich ein bisschen kanal schon gebt
ihr auf eine tortenplatte zu beziehende
tortenplatte die hard 30 zentimeter im
durchmesser das heißt sie ist etwas
größer als die torte und da werde ich
sie später auch drauf servieren
hier setzt jetzt den ersten boden drauf
und wer möchte kann ihn jetzt mit
orangensaft trinken orangensaft finde
ich passt geschmacklich auch sehr gut
mit dazu aber müsste auch gar nicht
trinken denn der teig ist wirklich auch
sehr saftig
da kommt jetzt ein drittel von der
pistazien creme drauf
jetzt kommt noch der deckel drauf und da
habe ich mir immer den boden auf und
drehten um dann habe ich nämlich gleich
eine richtig gerade oberfläche auf der
torte und es beim motiv dort eben immer
sehr ideal
und wenn der deckel jetzt drauf sitzt
kann man mit ein bisschen rest creme
auch noch ein paar feinheiten
ausgleichen
so wie hier einfach nur ein bisschen
gremien rand damit der deckel oben schön
gerade ist und damit jetzt auch die
seiten gerade werden könnt ihr
beispielsweise wieder den tortenring
nehmen
drumherum schließen ein bisschen fest
drücken und verschließen
jetzt sieht man auch dass die oberfläche
schön gerade ist und ich später einfach
wenig ausgleichen muss mit der garage
jetzt kommt noch der torten retter
obendrauf und die torte muss für
mindestens eine halbe stunde bis stunde
in den kühlschrank
jetzt nach der schulzeit löse ich den
torten rahmen wieder mit einem
tortenring messer
jetzt werde ich die torte einmal dünn
mit der kanal streichen so werden die
krümel gebunden
dann wird sie kurz gekühlt und dann
nochmal komplett glatt gestrichen
befördern der von dann drauf kommt und
wie ich das schritt für schritt mache
habe ich euch bereits in einem anderen
video gezeigt
die torte sitzt den klassen jetzt werde
ich ein telefon dann weiß kneten und
ausrollen und dann noch gar überlegen
ich habe jetzt hier ein kilo vanille
fondant ausgerollt und jetzt nehme ich
meine torte und weil es die oberfläche
schon so etwas angetrocknet ist
bespricht sie mit etwas back trends gray
so haftet davon dann auch gut an der
torte einfach mit den händen drunter und
fondant glatz darüber legen
jetzt werde ich gleich die überreste mit
dem marzipan besser weg schneiden und in
fondant dann glatt streichen
die torte isst eingekleidet jetzt werde
ich mich um die dekoration kümmern
zuerst werde ich den rand der torte
dekorieren das habe ich jetzt hier 500
gramm blauen von der bereits weiß
geknetet und werden dünn ausrollen und
zwar geht es jetzt endlich beim ausbau
stark oder mit den roma schicken
hab ich das lange band hier mal
ausgerollt und zeigt was ich machen
werde und habe ich jetzt hier eine
schablone aus papier und die habe ich
jetzt so gemacht dass ich hier schöne
bögen oben habe die benutze ich jetzt
als schablone auf dem blauen band jetzt
muss ich aber zuerst das blaue band
unten gerade schneiden
das mache ich jetzt hier mit dem
pizzaschneider und jetzt nämlich die
schablone als hilfe und setzt hier unten
das lineal an
dann kann nämlich dieses band ganz
gerade anliegen und ihr müsst jetzt
natürlich zuerst einmal den umfang der
torte aus messen also der durchmesser
bei mir 22 und der umfang sie etwa 70
zentimeter und jetzt können die
schablone da drauf legen
und hier oben die böden zurechtschneiden
und wenn s band dann lang genug ist
schneidet ihr vorne und hinten den teil
weg
und damit ist band jetzt beim transport
nicht beschädigt gilt werde es auf
diesen ausruf starb aufrollen
jetzt kann ich die torte wird etwas
essbarem geber bestreichen
dafür gebe ich ihnen jetzt in einen
teller und nehmen einen großen pinsel
dafür und damit ich da jetzt nicht so
hoch bestreichen nämlich hier wieder die
schablone und kann das hier unten mit
randstreifen
so und jetzt kann ich das hier ansetzen
und bündig und ausrollen
und den übergang hinweg schneiden und
jede torte hat eine rückseite deswegen
ist es nicht schlimm wenn sie sich
bündig abschließen würde
mit dem von dieter schön andrücken
dann gehen auch die luftbläschen raus
und davon dann klickt gut an
um die toppits weiter zu dekorieren habe
ich jetzt hier vier farben an modelliert
schokolade bereits geknetet und
ausgerollt und werde jetzt für dieses
muster noch kleine elemente machen und
zwar hab ich mir hier so eine schablone
gemacht die sie jetzt vielleicht
kompliziert aus ist aber ganz einfach
ich brauche dafür nämlich nur diese zwei
ausstiege einmal etwas kleiner und einen
etwas größeren ziemlich den kleinen
ausstecher und stellt jetzt mal ganz
viele kreise aus
und jetzt nämlich den großen ausstecher
und meine schablone habe ich übrigens
caesar streifen draufgeklebt man kann es
nicht besser halten und jetzt lege ich
die schablone auf den kreis also die
schablonen habe ich einfach mit dem
gleichen ausstellern auch gemacht und
jetzt wird hier rechts und links des weg
gesprochen und dann habe ich das eben
immer auf der gleichen höhe weg
gestochen
jetzt habe ich alle ausgestorbenen habe
jetzt auch noch ein paar gelbe
hergestellt und die gelben habe ich mit
weißer modelle schokolade gemacht und
die einfach mit lebensmittel verpasste
gelb eingefärbt vorher mit montage- oder
schokolade eignet sich das ist auch
super denn ich habe jetzt so ein
bisschen liegen lassen jetzt sind sie
ein bisschen fester und verformen sich
auch nicht wenn ich sie jetzt an klasse
nehmt euch ein stück max papier oder
backpapier und es streit ich jetzt mit
etwas kokosfett ein und das papier habe
ich jetzt schon so zurecht geschnitten
dass es die höhe der torte praktisch
darstellt dann braucht ihr nur ein
kleines stück und da werde ich jetzt das
muster was jetzt auf die torte anbringen
möchte vorher anbringen und es
vereinfacht mir dann so ein bisschen die
arbeit so dass klebe ich jetzt mit etwas
kokosfett an mein unterlage also an
diese schablone einfach so als
orientierung und auf die oberfläche
kommt auch noch ein bisschen kokosfett
jetzt nehme ich die einzelnen stücke und
klebt ihr hier drauf und legt sozusagen
mein muster hier an
nichts liegt jetzt immer so ein bisschen
versetzt also die obere reihe und dann
kommt immer in die mitte in die in
dieser öffnung die untere reihe
ich habe jetzt überlegt noch ein paar
gold einzufärben dafür nehme ich jetzt
die roten und pinsel sie mit etwas
wasser
und dann nehme ich einen anderen
trockenen pinsel und nehmen hier das
gold vorab prüfer und kann sie jetzt
auch wie pinsel
die goldenen müsste jetzt auf jeden fall
mit der gold seite nach unten auf das
papier geben denn später wird es ja an
die torte geklebt und das praktisch die
rückseite wieder vorne und hier unten
muss jetzt ein bisschen was anpassen und
zwar kommen 13 paar teile dran wo man
eben nur die oberseite sieht das heißt
dass nehmen jetzt einfach ein paar
kreise und schnellste dann unten bündig
mit dem wachs papier ab
jetzt bestreite ich die teile mit etwas
kleber einfach auf der rückseite
und jetzt könnt ihr mit hilfe des wachs
papiers die teile an der torte
befestigen geht natürlich auch ohne ihr
könnt auch alle einzeln ankleben
dann ab 10 jetzt können natürlich noch
mal mit den fingern so ein paar
angleichen
ja
und falls ihr das ist ohne wachs papier
machen wollt einfach mit dem pinsel
etwas kleber anbringen und die einzelnen
teile ankleben
der rand ist soweit fertig werde ich die
oberseite dekorieren das habe ich jetzt
hier ein stück wachs papier oder
backpapier können da auch nehmen
zurechtgeschnitten im durchmesser der
torte und kann jetzt darauf arbeiten und
kann die torte ist aber wieder kühl
stellen dann muss ich nämlich jetzt
nicht ewig dran rum dekoriert sondern
macht das jetzt erst mal hier und kann
es dann später drauf setzen
das wachstum hier muss jetzt erst mal
wieder mit etwas kokosfett eingestrichen
werden dann bleibt die dekoration gut
dran kleben und dann stellte ich jetzt
immer aus modelle schokolade oder auch
aus fondant dekorationen aus und mache
hier oben so ein orientalisches muss da
hin
das habe ich hier noch ein paar blaue
kreise gemacht und mit weiß innen drin
die klebe ich jetzt auch gleich dran
aber zuerst nehme ich jetzt hier dieses
diese weiße blume kannst hier mit ich
reinsetzen
jetzt nehme ich das papier nochmal zur
hilfe und kann jetzt in diese ecken die
kreise reihen sitzen
um die torte noch fertig zu dekorieren
und feinheiten zu machen werde ich jetzt
ein icing machen und zwar ist es eine
eiweiß sprits klausur
dafür nehme ich jetzt 250 gramm
puderzucker und etwas eiweißpulver kam
es in pulverform nehmen oder man nimmt
ein eiweiß aber so hat man eben kein
rohes ei weiß mit drin sondern das
pulver davon nehme ich jetzt drei
esslöffel und jetzt etwa 1,5 bis zwei
esslöffel wasser so dass eine
dickflüssige konsistenz entsteht
manchmal auch mal ein bisschen mehr
und jetzt teile ich das eben drei
portionen und verpasst damit
lebensmittel verpasste ein
da
ziemlich spritzbeutel unternehmen
steinweg spritzbeutel und kann vorne
sondern ganz kleine loch schüler
einsetzen
ihr könnt es aber auch ohne lok schule
machen also könnte es auch einen
gefrierbeutel zum beispiel leben die
lochmühle weglassen um vorne nur eine
ganz kleine spitze wegschneiden
satie spritzbeutel ziehe ich jetzt über
diese gläser treffer
jetzt kann ich die ihre skripte
einfüllen und jetzt kann ich mit der
einspritzdüse auf die torte spritzen ihr
könnt immer gerne vorher auf einem
papier oder auf dem teller ein bisschen
muss ausprobieren
sie wird vier kleine musikstücke
zurechtgeschnitten und bei diesen
orientalischen fließen ist es ja auch
immer so da ist immer einen haupt du
musst du eigentlich drauf und der rest
wenn ich immer so kleine mosaiksteinchen
man hebt sich dieses muster immer schön
hervor für streiche ich die torte also
die stellen wo ich das musik drauf haben
möchte mit etwas wasser und streut dann
die mosaik stückchen mit drauf
das mosaik muss das jetzt fertig jetzt
stelle ich sie dort in den kühlschrank
räume bisschen auf und da muss ich
eigentlich nur noch das skateboard
übersehen und die restlichen deko
elemente machen
jetzt werde ich hier das skateboard noch
über zehn dafür nehme ich jetzt wieder
ein bisschen von dem s bahn kleber den
hab ich jetzt mit bisschen wasser
vermischt und kann denn jetzt hier
großflächig auftragen und jetzt habe ich
hier ein schwarzes band aus finnland
bereits ausgeschnitten
das lege ich jetzt hier herum das muss
man jetzt einfach ein bisschen denen
dann legt sich es auch coaches drumherum
so jetzt gebe ich noch zum schluss
buchstaben auf und zwar habe ich jetzt
etwa weg also gesegnetes fest auf
arabisch geschrieben mit modelle
schokolade ausgestochen und mit gold ein
gebot hat jetzt lebe ich die hier noch
trauma will die frage kommt ist kam ein
kleber ist ja es ist lebensmittel kleber
ganz normal hatte im scherz die ganze
zeit benutzt also alles gut
das sind probieren menschen ja und auch
typisch heißt ja auf türkisch bei
damaskus beirut oder beide kosten genau
das mobile ich nämlich auch mit drin
so jetzt können wir die torte probieren
die teller der moritz ich schneide jetzt
an
eins kann ich mir es auch ganz gut an
der blume im innern orientieren
dann habe ich gleich mit ich und ich
muss sagen das hast du ja auch noch
nicht von privater tor des erstens und
zweitens finde ich das machen so wenige
an einem ramadan
das war ein kollektor dem ankunft dieses
erinnert sich das ein bisschen dass
viele leute es nachmachen oder zunächst
zu ähnlich machen wo dafür ist
vielleicht sogar noch besser machen
nicht auch ein ganz anderes fenster
aber ich finde den geschmack der ist
wirklich also ich hab noch nie probiert
habe ich freunde jetzt wirklich drauf
und es ist eine riesenüberraschung dafür
zu machen wirklich oft ist wirklich
unterricht hat 60 das grün ist es toll
dass es nie bis 1900 probiert dann
probiert mir also hier kupfer dessen
nennt das ist auch schön die pistazien
jahre drin
und zwar was ganz anderes sondern ich
war also wirklich aber ich finde dass es
bis jetzt der beste zeit für eine
freundin chinas gegessen
ich fand ihn auch zum verarbeiten so
heißt es so schön saftig aber trotzdem
schön fest und ich glaube den dackel tag
mache ich jetzt wirklich mal öfter und
mannschaft machen was muss man kann
schon mal ganz normalen kuchen machen
nur mit diesem tag also im ganzen
barrera zurück zu normalen wiese und
sandkuchen weil es findet auch dass der
teig super lecker schmeckt nämlich schon
gemacht hast die torte im innern
übrigens aus oder macht es mal wirklich
nach den doppeln ich so wahnsinnig es
freut uns und die pistazien creme
schmeckt gut raus es freut mich ja
jedenfalls sitzt die torte optisch und
geschmacklich ziemlich orientalisch
windig und ja ich hoffe dass er die
torte nach macht und freue mich wenn ihr
mir ein foto auf facebook und auf ins
programm sendet und uns da markiert dann
kann ich mir nimmt alle schönen torten
anschauen und jetzt wünschen wir euch
auf jeden fall ein ganz tolles
ramadanfest der ramadan monat geht ja
noch ein paar tage
aber ich hoffe dass ich euch mit diesem
video mit dieser torte ein bisschen
inspirieren konnte bitte mach ich
wirklich machen
wir werden überrascht sein wie pohlig
mit martin schmitt in den usa ziehen
sagt dir noch im guten appetit und euch
viel spaß zum nachbacken bis zum
nächsten mal
das ist schon immer ganz schön zu sagen